هناك شيء اخر لا يستطيع بري ولا الغرب
بشكل عام ان يمنعه ان يمنعه وهو دخول
النفط الروسي للسوق فالختلاف على ان الحرب
الميدانيه في اوكرانيا توازيها حرب
اقتصاديه اخذت اشكالا مختلفه ابرزها حرب
الطاقه التي اشعلت اسعار المحروقات حول
العالم روسيا التي تعد ثالث اكبر منتج
للنفط في العالم وجدت نفسها مضطره للتكيف
مع الوضع الجديد الذي فرض عليها بعد
العقوبات الصادره من المعسكر الغربي موسكو
نجحت لحد الان في ايجاد بدائل مكانتها من
تجاوز العقوبات الغربيه ولو مرحله والدليل
هو ان انتاج روسيا من النفط لم يتراجع بعد
مرور نحو شهرين على بدء تطبيق العقوبات
الغربيه
فكيف التفت موسكو على هذه العقوبات قبل
الحديث عن مخرج الروسي يجب توضيح الطبيعه
العقوبات التي فرضتها الدول الغربيه هذا
مهم فالعقوبات التي اعلنت عنها مجموعه سبع
تضمنت حضره استيراد النفط الروسي في
اوروبا لتنضم الاخيره بذلك الى الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في هذا السياق اضافه
الى ذلك تم تسقيفه سعر النفط الروسيه عند
60 دولارا للبرميل في الاسواق الاخرى كما
تقتضي عقوبه سقف السعر منع الشركات
الغربيه من توفير ناقلات لشحن نفط الروسي
فضلا عن منع تقديم خدمات التامين للنقل
البحري للناقلات اذا كان النفط مشحون اذا
كان سعره اعلى من سقف السعر المحدد
[موسيقى]
صحيفه وسط حتى اذا كيف استمر تدفق الى
مختلف الاسواق العالميه بسعر يتجاوز سقف
المحدد في العقوبات الغربيه
بعد بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
وهو مصطلح يطلق على الناقلات المستعده
للالتفاف على العقوبات لنقل النفط الخام
وهي ممارسه شائعه تستخدمها ايران كذلك
فنزويلا منذ فتره طويله لتجنب عقوبه النفط
الغربيه
لشركات خارجيه في بلدان ذات قوانين اكثر
تساهلا
ناقلات اسطول الظل لديهم معلومات محدوده
مع حكومات او بنوك الولايات المتحده او
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي فان خوفهم من
التعرض للعقوبات يبقى محدوده